[Music]
as americans struggled to move on from
the events at the capitol building last
week
there have been calls for unity from
both political parties
calls to end the divisiveness that
plagues our country so we can become
a truly united nation and frankly
i think that's a great idea
[Music]
we will all come together
to celebrate this great land
we've had our differences before
but i can say i understand
i understand you don't think i deserve
health care
or a living wage and your refusal to see
me as a human being
does not fill me with rage unless unite
let's all get together
let's unite and see where this thing
goes
let's unite the members of the proud
boys
alongside the bernie bros let's stuff
together
with no ifs ands or buts
with people who hate our girls
[Music]
i understand you may have voted trump
and you may or may not have a gun
what i truly want is to be around you
that sounds like a lot of fun
i believe that we can come together
and heal this rift even though
if i married your son you
would jump off a glimp let's unite it
doesn't matter what you've done in the
past
let's unite consequences don't exist
let's unite you're all like moga
let's come together and make sure you
learn
nothing i want you to learn nothing
learn nothing about being the type of
white supremacist you won't even
admit that they are and get folded right
back into society with your
insane ideals even though in this
scenario i'm the one that suffers
[Music]
tonight
[Music]
you